hear the music I'm not some Hollywood
director that decided to jump on the
comic book bandwagon I'm a pretty
hardcore fan 400 a month habit Deadpool
is a very grounded comic book hero he
lives in an apartment and he deals with
people and his life is not filled with
chrome and fast Jetson and everything
else in fact I think it's kind of the
perfect contrast to the shinier sides of
the Marvel Universe we can make you
better make you a superhero that's known
as a visual artist and someone who loves
beautiful art and well written stories
and characters that you care about it's
kind of the perfect combination of all
of those things plus I'm kind of a
sucker for a hero's journey comic books
are sort of the perfect medium for epic
storytelling and imax is all about epic
film presentation so you bring those two
things together and you got epic squared
it's a great way to see them come to
life yay you may be wondering why the
red suit well that's so bad guys can't
see me bleed this guy's got the right
idea he wore the brown pants I couldn't
be more proud of the work that everybody
put into it it's a great honor to do a
movie and have millions of people around
the world see it but to see it in an
imax which is this premiere format it
just doesn't get any better than that oh
I am very turned on right now
you